so
i'm so sleepy
i feel like running
you must be shang ling
sorry mr trough i heard the whole story
oh he's gonna let her have it
please help me promote my meat
huh sorry if i was little rash
springvale has built
its reputation on top quality meat
products but this reputation is so far
limited to monster when i heard that the
great maestro xiang ling herself was in
monstat
maestro haven't you heard she's the one
behind juan mean restaurant her unique
take on cooking ingredients is behind
some of the best
you're too kind i just try to cook
things that are with a top-notch chef
cooking top-notch cuisine
i don't i only ever think about how to
make tasty dishes
i never limit myself to specific you use
bore me all the time anyway
surely the issue is that's
there's no such thing as normaling i
will not stand for having my creativity
shackled by what ingredients i can
what you know we did come to apologize
couldn't you be a little more flexible
it's one thing to apologize but it's
another thing entirely to change the way
i approach
cooking what's that smell
it's gorgeous
hello may i have it sorry
i've taken all the wow it must be
delicious
yeah good point why didn't hmm
maybe he feels that monsta cuisine can't
compete with but i disagree
i don't think my cooking well then show
me what you got
sorry but customer feedback like oh that
tasted good
is no use to me if i wanted feedback
that's me
it's really you as it happens i have one
of today's
that depends on the ratio of fat to meat
with this cut
i would probably roast it over a ginseng
flour
but the melted fat would make i know
that's why it's a garnet
i've tried it before if you baste the
petals in oil and then throw in some
joyous chilies grown at a high altitude
where
the petals absorb the saltiness from the
sea salt the chili spice
and the umami of the tender freshly
grilled steak while oh
that's pure overkill you're going all
out on the trimmings and doing no
justice to the meat whatsoever
who wants to eat a roast when you can
taste everything except whoa whoa whoa
stop arguing
well there's only one surefire way out
of a cooking this i declare suits me
if you can't beat my cooking it'll show
that draft all right
but it and if you lose you have to add
ma with a caption saying
this special it's a deal i'm off to get
ingredients
i will see you wait wait
let's try and get